Jacques 1, verset 16 à 27.
« Ainsi que tout homme soit pronte à écouter, lent à parler, lent à se mettre en colère, car la colère de l'homme n'accomplit pas la justice de Dieu. »
C'est pourquoi, rejetant toute souillure et tout excès de malice, recevez avec douceur la parole qui a été plotée en vous et qui peut sauver vos âmes.
Mettez en pratique la parole et ne vous bornez pas à l'écouter en vous trompant vous-même par de faux raisonnements.
Car si quelqu'un écoute la parole et ne la met pas en pratique, il est semblable à un homme qui regarde dans un miroir son visage naturel et qui, après s'être regardé, s'en va et oublie aussitôt quel il était.
Mais celui qui aura plongé les regards dans la loi parfaite, la loi de la liberté, et qui aura persévéré n'étant pas un auditeur oublieux, mais se mettant à l'heure, celui-là sera heureux dans son activité.
Si quelqu'un croit être religieux sans tenir sa langue en bride, mais en trompant son cœur, la religion de cet homme est vaine.
La religion pure et sans tâche, devant Dieu notre Père, consiste à visiter les orphelins et les veuves dans leurs afflictions et à se préserver des souillures du monde.
Amen. Vous pouvez vous asseoir.
Donc, comme son nom l'indique, cette lettre fut rédigée par Jacques.
Il y a plusieurs Jacques dans la parole, mais celui-ci était un des frères de notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ, ou demi-frère, on peut dire aussi.
Et l'apôtre Paul lui-même qualifia ce Jacques en question de colonne de l'Église.
Donc, ça nous donne une idée des responsabilités importantes que Jacques exerça au sein de l'Église de Jérusalem, dont il était un des anciens,
et dont il présida le Concile, qui se déroula en l'an 49 après Jésus-Christ.
C'était, selon les témoignages de l'époque, un homme d'une grande piété, imprégné des enseignements du Christ,
qu'il encourageait ses frères et sœurs à mettre en pratique avec zèle, comme en témoigne cette lettre,
qu'il adressa donc aux douze tribus dispersées du peuple de Dieu, comme on le lit au premier verset.
Et Jacques connaissait probablement, personnellement, plusieurs membres de ces églises,
dans lesquelles sa lettre était destinée à circuler, pour être lue publiquement.
Car ces églises se sont formées après que les premiers chrétiens de Jérusalem,
qui étaient majoritairement d'origine juive, durent fuir la ville à cause de la persécution,
comme vous pouvez le lire en acte 8, au tout début du chapitre.
Et ce point contextuel a son importance parce qu'il nous aide à mieux comprendre le choix des thèmes abordés par Jacques dans sa lettre,
et surtout la façon dont il aborde ces thèmes, les enfases qu'il met sur ces thèmes.
Vous constaterez que le fait que ces auditeurs étaient majoritairement des chrétiens d'arrière-plan juif
aura à nouveau une grande importance, une grande influence sur notre manière de comprendre les versets 26 et 27.
Donc retenez bien ce point de contexte.
Les auditeurs de Jacques sont des chrétiens, majoritairement d'origine juive,
qui ont fui de Jérusalem à cause de la violente persécution qu'ils subissaient.
Et rien qu'avec cette précision contextuelle, nous comprenons mieux pourquoi les thèmes principaux de cette lettre sont de manière assez logique
la persécution, la pauvreté, la vraie religion, la foi et les bonnes œuvres.
Et comment nous pouvons réunir tous ces thèmes en un thème principal de cette lettre,
qui serait la mise à l'épreuve de la vraie foi.
C'est ce thème principal qui nous permet d'unifier toutes ces exhortations qui sont très variées,
et souvent pratiques, et que Jacques adresse aux membres de ces églises dispersées.
Car en effet, les auditeurs de Jacques, les membres de ces églises, font face à des menaces variées,
mais qui ont cela en commun qu'elles mettent toutes en péril leur foi.
Ils cherchent donc à les mettre en garde contre ces dangers,
que peut-être pour certains ils ignorent ou négligent,
ou devant lesquels certains d'entre eux ont capitulé, ont renié leur foi ou sont très proches de le faire.
Je vous invite maintenant à garder votre Bible ouverte, si ce n'est pas déjà fait, au premier chapitre,
afin que nous puissions rapidement retracer ces exhortations de Jacques qui aboutissent aux versets 26 et 27.
Donc de manière générale, face à la persécution qu'ils subissaient,
ces chrétiens pouvaient être tentés d'abandonner la foi,
et de revenir au judaïsme qu'ils avaient quitté.
Ou au moins à un compromis entre le christianisme et le judaïsme,
un compromis suffisant pour leur éviter cette persécution dure de la part des juifs et des romains,
tout en n'abandonnant pas complètement, selon eux en tout cas, la foi chrétienne.
Et ce point précis, ce danger précis, était un des enjeux majeurs de l'Église à ce moment-là.
Et il n'est donc pas étonnant de retrouver les mêmes avertissements,
les mêmes encouragements de la part de Paul,
dans sa lettre aux Galates, par exemple, que nous étudions en ce moment,
dans sa lettre aux Romains,
ou dans l'Épître aux Hébreux, que nous étudions aussi avec Loïc.
Et c'est aussi le cas pour Jacques.
Et c'est pour cela que des versets 2 à 4, en particulier,
il encourage ces chrétiens persécutés à persévérer dans la foi,
malgré les grandes épreuves qu'ils traversent.
Et face à de telles épreuves,
les croyants peuvent facilement tomber dans le cynisme,
et finir par ne plus prier, ou bien prier avec des involtures,
avec, de manière plus simple, un manque de foi.
Et je pense que, sans même parler de persécution,
nous avons tous pu expérimenter cela,
dans une certaine mesure, dans notre vie chrétienne.
Lorsque les choses vont mal, notre foi peut faiblir.
Et bien Jacques exhorte les membres de ces églises,
malgré tout ce qu'ils peuvent subir,
à toujours prier avec foi.
Il fait cela des versets 5 à 8.
L'église de Jérusalem, dont nous avons parlé,
était assez pauvre.
Et c'est aussi pour cela,
et pour faire face à ce manque de subsistance matérielle et financière,
que cette communauté mettait en commun les biens de chacun,
comme nous le disons aussi en acte.
Et ces églises, auxquelles Jacques écrit,
étant issues de cette diaspora de l'église de Jérusalem,
avaient donc probablement le même niveau de vie.
probablement même plus faible encore,
du fait d'avoir dû laisser derrière eux le peu qu'ils avaient,
d'avoir été dispersés,
et peut-être de ne plus pouvoir se soutenir,
comme ils le faisaient à Jérusalem.
Et ce manque de subsistance matérielle et financière
pouvait alimenter leur rancœur envers Dieu.
Leur convoitise aussi,
envers ceux qui possédaient plus.
Et donc, à nouveau,
les pousser à renier leur foi
pour retrouver un niveau de vie plus confortable.
Une vie moins difficile matériellement.
Et c'est pour cela que,
des versets 9 à 11,
Jacques rappelle aux riches et aux pauvres
que tous deux finiront par mourir.
Que les richesses terrestres n'y changeront rien.
Et qu'ils devraient avant tout garder les yeux fixés
sur la récompense
qui attend ceux qui vont persévérer dans les épreuves.
Cette récompense étant la couronne de vie,
comme il le dit au verset 12,
qui est la vie éternelle.
Mais qui d'entre nous peut se vanter
de n'avoir jamais murmuré contre Dieu
lorsque la vie devenait trop difficile ?
Qui ne sait jamais chercher d'excuses
dans le fait que Dieu nous éprouve
au-delà de nos forces
pour agir selon les désirs de notre chair ?
Et c'est malheureusement une tendance
que notre vieille nature,
toujours corrompue par le péché,
même après notre conversion,
garde et qui ressurgit
lorsque Dieu nous éprouve,
lorsqu'il nous fait passer par le creuser
pour purifier et affiner notre foi.
Et dans ces moments-là,
nous devons nous rappeler
cet encouragement que Jacques adresse
à ses auditeurs des versets 13 à 17.
Dieu est parfait
et tout ce qui vient de lui est bon,
même les épreuves,
dans notre vie.
A chaque fois que nous désobéissons à Dieu
ou que nous restons passifs devant ses exigences,
ce n'est pas parce que sa providence
nous conduit sur des sentiers insurmontables,
mais bien parce que la convoitise
et la faiblesse de notre chair
nous poussent à choisir un chemin plus facile,
plus rapide
et en apparence plus bénéfique pour nous.
Mais nous ne devons pas seulement apprendre
à ne pas injustement accuser Dieu
lorsque nous chutons dans les épreuves,
nous devons aussi apprendre
à compter ses bienfaits
et à le remercier pour tous les dons,
toutes les grâces
qu'il renouvelle généreusement envers nous chaque jour.
Le plus grand de ses dons
étant notre nouvelle naissance,
selon sa volonté,
par la parole de vérité.
Vous avez peut-être déjà entendu parler
de la chaîne d'or du salut
dans l'Épître aux Romains,
au chapitre 8.
Cette séquence qui décrit
l'ordre logique de notre salut,
la préscience de Dieu,
la prédestination,
l'appel, la justification
et enfin la glorification.
Eh bien, en verset 18
du chapitre 1 de Jacques,
comment ce que nous pourrions appeler
la chaîne d'or de la parole de Dieu
qui s'étend jusqu'à la fin du verset 27,
jusqu'à la fin du chapitre.
Car si jusqu'ici,
comme nous l'avons vu,
les thèmes abordés par Jacques
sont unis plutôt par ce contexte
de persécution
que subissent les auditeurs,
nous entrons à partir du verset 18
dans une séquence
très explicitement unifiée
autour du thème de la parole de Dieu.
Au milieu de toutes les tribulations
que ces croyants traversent,
de ces personnes chères
qu'ils peuvent perdre au long du chemin,
dans les flots agités
de cette vie terrestre tumultueuse,
Jacques les encourage
à lever les yeux vers le ciel,
à contempler leur Père Céleste,
immuable dans son être
et dans ses promesses,
qui a voulu,
dans sa grâce
et sa seule volonté,
faire d'eux ses enfants
par sa parole de vérité,
par la proclamation
de l'évangile
de son fils unique Jésus-Christ
qui est devenu leur frère.
Mes chers frères et sœurs,
dit-il,
souvenez-vous que si vous êtes
ainsi accablés pour un temps,
c'est parce que ce Dieu si bon,
alors que vous étiez encore ses ennemis,
a voulu faire de vous ses enfants
pour l'éternité.
Ne regardez pas qu'aux contraintes,
ne regardez pas qu'à la souffrance
et au sacrifice de cette vie sur terre,
mais regardez aux privilèges,
regardez aux récompenses célestes,
regardez au repos éternel
que Jésus-Christ a acquis pour vous
et vous offre gracieusement
à vous qui êtes nés de Dieu.
Ce don parfait et immérité
de leur nouvelle naissance,
de notre nouvelle naissance,
nous, chrétiens,
nous le devons entièrement à Dieu
qui nous a engendrés
par sa parole de vérité.
C'est le premier maillon essentiel
de cette chaîne de la parole
et de toute la lettre de Jacques en réalité.
Car rappelez-vous bien,
qu'il ne sert à rien d'exhorter
à l'obéissance
et aux affections religieuses,
aux affections spirituelles plutôt,
des êtres spirituellement morts.
Nous devons d'abord naître de nouveau.
Nous devons d'abord être engendrés par Dieu,
devenir ses enfants adoptés
par notre union avec Christ.
Avant qu'on nous enseigne comment
un tel enfant de Dieu doit penser,
aimer,
obéir et agir.
Inverser cet ordre,
c'est tomber dans le légalisme
ou la justification par les œuvres
et prêcher la nouvelle naissance.
Sans prêcher aussi l'obéissance
et la conformité à la loi de Dieu,
c'est tomber dans l'extrême opposé
qui est l'antinomisme.
Commençons donc à dérouler
cette chaîne de la parole
qui va nous mener jusqu'au verset 26 et 27.
D'abord donc,
nous sommes engendrés par la parole,
par l'action du Saint-Esprit en nous
qui utilise la prédication fidèle de l'Évangile.
Nous devenons les enfants de Dieu.
Et notez donc,
et c'est important,
que ces exhortations de Jacques
jusqu'à la fin du chapitre
s'adressent bien à des chrétiens,
à des hommes et des femmes
qui ont professé leur foi en Christ
après avoir été appelés
dans la prédication,
par la prédication.
Ensuite, au verset 19,
nous devons donc apprendre
à être des enfants
qui écoutent la voix de leur père
et qui, pour ainsi dire,
ne lui coupent pas la parole
lorsqu'ils s'adressent à nous.
Nous devons mettre de côté
tout ce qui en nous
ou autour de nous
peut être un obstacle
non seulement à notre écoute,
mais aussi à notre réception
de cette parole.
Cette parole de Dieu,
notre Père.
Nous ne devons pas l'écouter
avec un esprit de dispute,
de confrontation,
de doute,
d'orgueil ou de suffisance.
Nous devons l'écouter
avec humilité
afin de la recevoir
avec douceur
et soumission.
Alors seulement,
cette parole pourra
prendre racine en nous
et commencer
à nous sanctifier
en traduisant
notre nouvelle naissance
en actes visibles
et objectifs
par la pratique
de bonnes œuvres
dans notre vie.
Et c'est pourquoi,
à partir du verset 22,
Jacques poursuit
cette chaîne
de la parole de Dieu
en nous encourageant
à la mettre en pratique.
Nous sommes engendrés
par la parole,
nous écoutons la parole,
nous recevons la parole
et nous mettons en pratique
la parole.
Et dans ces six derniers versets
du chapitre 1,
Jacques va présenter
trois catégories de personnes,
trois attitudes possibles
face à la parole de Dieu.
Deux attitudes négatives
et une attitude positive.
Et nous avons déjà étudié
deux catégories,
deux attitudes
des versets 22 à 25.
La première attitude négative,
c'est celle des personnes
qui écoutent la parole,
qui lisent la parole,
peut-être même régulièrement,
peut-être même attentivement
avec une apparence d'humilité,
mais dont la vie
n'est en réalité
absolument pas impactée
par ce qu'ils entendent
ou ce qu'ils lisent.
Ces personnes
écoutent la prédication
et elles oublient aussitôt
les exhortations
de cette prédication.
Elles constatent
les changements à faire
dans leur vie,
mais elles ne prennent
aucune mesure concrète.
Elles approuvent
la vérité de la parole,
mais elles ne l'appliquent pas.
Et une telle attitude,
nous dit Jacques,
est celle d'un homme
ou d'une femme
qui se trompe lui-même
par de faux raisonnements.
Ils se considèrent
enfants de Dieu,
mais tous les premiers
maillons de la chaîne
sont inutiles
car celles-ci se brisent
aux maillons
de la mise en pratique
de la parole.
La religion de cet homme
est vaine.
La foi de cet homme
est morte.
Un homme dont la vie
est caractérisée
par une telle attitude
dans laquelle
il s'obstine
à écouter
sans mettre en pratique
n'est pas un enfant de Dieu,
malgré les illusions
dont il se berce,
malgré les faux raisonnements
qu'il a mis en place
dans ses pensées.
La deuxième catégorie
que nous avons étudiée,
positive,
cette fois-ci,
correspond aux personnes
qui, contrairement
aux premières,
continuent d'avancer
sur cette chaîne
de la parole
en mettant en pratique
ce qu'elles écoutent,
ce qu'elles lisent,
ce qu'elles reçoivent.
Vivifiée
et soutenue
par le Saint-Esprit,
l'enfant de Dieu
constate
toujours plus
à quel point
la loi de Dieu
est bonne
et que plus
il redevient
un serviteur
et un adorateur
de l'Éternel,
plus il renoue
progressivement
avec sa véritable
nature humaine
telle que Dieu
l'a créée
et plus il se sent
à nouveau libre
et heureux.
En lisant
les mots de Jacques
à la fin du verset 25,
nous aurions pu croire
que ce maillon
de la mise en pratique
de la parole
était le dernier
de cette chaîne.
Mais en réalité,
il en manque encore un
que Jacques présente
dans les deux versets suivants
sur lesquels
nous allons maintenant
nous pencher.
Mais avant d'examiner
ensemble ces versets,
je me sens poussé,
chers frères et sœurs,
à vous avertir
que ces mots de Jacques
que nous avons étudiés
et que nous allons étudier
sont difficiles.
Ils sont difficiles
car ils ne nous laissent
pas d'autre choix
que de nous examiner
nous-mêmes.
et de nous remettre
en question
si c'est nécessaire
par rapport
à l'authenticité
de notre foi.
Ce qui est toujours
un exercice sensible.
Tout au long
de l'histoire
de l'Église,
il y a eu
beaucoup de discussions
cherchant à définir
et à clarifier
les critères
qui permettent
d'identifier
la vraie foi chrétienne,
la seule foi
qui nous justifie
et qui nous octroie
la vie éternelle
en Jésus-Christ.
Et après tout,
si nous sommes convaincus
en tant que protestants
que la foi
est le seul
et unique
moyen
par lequel Dieu
peut nous justifier,
nous adopter
et nous glorifier
tout cela
en Jésus-Christ seul,
n'est-ce pas
la question
la plus importante
que nous puissions
nous poser ?
Suis-je sûr
de posséder
cette foi
salvatrice ?
Je crois
qu'il s'agit
en effet
de la question
la plus importante
qu'un être humain
puisse se poser
et donc
que la réponse
que nous apporterons
à cette question
est elle aussi
extrêmement importante.
Comment savoir
si je possède
cette foi
salvatrice,
qui sauve
en Jésus-Christ seul ?
Quelque part,
toute la lettre de Jacques
est une réponse
à cette question
existentielle
et cela a du sens
car il écrit
à des personnes
qui ont renoncé
à tout
pour la cause
de l'Évangile,
pour suivre
Jésus-Christ
et qui sont assaillis
peut-être jour et nuit
que ce soit
par leur chair
ou par le diable
qui cherchent
tous deux
à les convaincre
que les sacrifices
qu'ils font
n'en valent
sûrement pas la peine.
Peut-être
qu'ils se sont trompés
en choisissant
de suivre le Christ.
Peut-être
que cette foi
chrétienne
est finalement
une imposture
et que la vraie foi
reste le judaïsme
qu'ils ont quitté.
Et même si leur foi
est la bonne,
peut-être que les bénéfices
et les récompenses
que Dieu promet
à travers cette foi
ne sont pas
à la hauteur
des sacrifices
qu'ils font
dans cette vie.
Peut-être
qu'un compromis
moins douloureux,
moins coûteux
entre le christianisme
et le judaïsme
serait suffisant.
Voici
les questionnements
et les doutes
qui pouvaient assiéger
l'esprit
de ces chrétiens persécutés
et auxquels
Jacques souhaite
apporter des réponses
et des encouragements.
Il doit donc
combattre leurs doutes
non seulement
en leur assurant
objectivement
que leur foi chrétienne
est la seule
vraie foi
qui sauve,
mais aussi
en les aidant
à reconnaître
subjectivement
les signes
de la présence
de cette foi
dans leur vie
afin qu'ils soient
assurés
de ne pas supporter
en vain
toutes ces épreuves,
afin d'être sûrs
qu'ils possèdent
cette foi en Christ.
Et enfin,
Jacques doit combattre
leur lassitude,
leur apathie,
en les exhortant
à vivre pleinement
leur foi,
malgré les sacrifices,
car la récompense finale
en vaut largement
la peine.
Et bien entendu,
à certains endroits
de la lettre,
ces trois emphases
de Jacques
se réunissent
car elles ne sont pas
hermétiques l'une
envers l'autre,
bien au contraire.
Et c'est le cas
dans ces versets 26 et 27,
où Jacques nous rappelle
à la fois ce qu'est
la vraie religion
devant Dieu notre Père,
Coram Deo,
en nous indiquant
comment reconnaître
sa présence
ou son absence
dans notre vie.
Et oui,
il nous encourage
à mettre cette religion
pure et sans tâche
en pratique
une nouvelle fois.
Comment savoir
si je possède
la seule vraie foi
qui sauve ?
Ce que Jacques nous montre
dans ces versets,
c'est qu'il est possible
de répondre
à cette question
en nous basant
sur de mauvais critères
ou plutôt
sur des critères
insuffisants
pour au final
aboutir
à une illusion,
à un mirage
et nous tromper
nous-mêmes
plus ou moins
subtilement
sur l'authenticité
de notre foi
et donc
sur le salut
de notre âme.
Et frères et sœurs,
il n'y a pas
de situation
pire pour notre âme
que d'être persuadés
que nous sommes sauvés
alors que nous sommes
en réalité
toujours condamnés
à l'enfer.
Nous devons donc
accorder une grande
attention
aux avertissements
de Jacques
sur la façon
dont nous pouvons
faussement
nous convaincre
que nous possédons
la foi salvatrice.
La première façon
de nous tromper
nous-mêmes
sur l'authenticité
de notre foi,
nous l'avons vu
au verset 22,
c'est de nous borner
à écouter la parole
sans la mettre
en pratique.
Mais au verset 26,
Jacques nous met en garde
contre une autre façon,
plus subtile cette fois-ci,
de nous illusionner
nous-mêmes
quant à l'authenticité
de notre foi.
Car cette fois-ci,
il ne s'agit plus
de ne pas mettre
en pratique la parole,
mais de la mettre
en pratique
sans que notre cœur
ne soit engagé
et transformé
par cette mise
en pratique.
Il s'agit de mettre
en pratique la parole,
mais d'une façon
où notre cœur
n'est pas engagé
et n'est pas transformé
continuellement
par cette mise
en pratique,
à travers cette mise
en pratique
de la parole.
Il est intéressant
de noter que selon Jacques,
celui qui ne met pas
en pratique la parole
au verset 22
se trompe par de vingt raisonnements.
chez cette personne,
la parole ne franchit
même pas
la barrière intellectuelle
de son esprit,
seulement la barrière physique
de ses oreilles.
Dès que les mots
de la parole
entrent dans son esprit,
il y a toute une
machinerie charnelle
de raisonnements
trompeurs
qui se met en route
de façon à broyer
ses mots
jusqu'à ce qu'il n'en reste
rien à la fin
de la prédication
ou de sa lecture.
La parole ne passe
pas ce filtre
de vingt raisonnements
que son esprit
met automatiquement
en place
pour se tenir éloigné
de toute nécessité
de mise en pratique
des commandements
de Dieu
dans sa vie.
Mais pour le cas
du verset 26,
si la parole
a pu s'introduire
dans l'esprit
de cette personne,
en convaincre
les pensées
et même y prendre racine
jusqu'à le pousser
à pratiquer
de bonnes œuvres,
ses racines
ne sont cependant
pas descendues
jusque dans son cœur.
L'esprit
a été convaincu
mais le cœur,
lui,
n'a pas été touché.
Il n'a pas été transformé.
Et Jacques nous dit
qu'au même titre
que celui
qui ne pratique pas
la parole,
la religion
de cette personne
qui pratique
sans que son cœur
ne soit transformé,
elle aussi
est vaine.
La chaîne
de la parole
n'est complète
qu'avec ce dernier maillon
qui consiste
à circoncire
non seulement
la chair
par la mise en pratique
de la loi
mais aussi
à circoncire
le cœur.
L'obéissance
au commandement
de Dieu,
même la plus ailée,
n'a aucune valeur
devant Dieu,
n'a aucune pertinence
pour l'assurance
de notre salut
si notre cœur
n'est pas également
sanctifié
et consacré
à Dieu.
Plus nous progressons
sur cette chaîne
de la parole,
plus nous nous rapprochons
de l'essence
de la vraie foi,
de la religion pure
et sans tâche
et donc aussi
des impostures
les plus subtiles
et peut-être
les plus graves
dans lesquelles
nous pouvons tomber.
Et ce matin,
nous en sommes arrivés
au dernier maillon
de cette chaîne,
celui qui concerne
notre cœur.
Jacques nous a exhortés
sur les pensées
de notre esprit,
sur les actes
de notre corps
et maintenant il passe
aux dispositions
de notre cœur.
Et s'il aborde
ce sujet du cœur
en dernier,
c'est qu'à il sait
très bien que si nous
pouvons nous tromper
nous-mêmes
ou notre entourage
pour un temps
en tout cas,
avec nos raisonnements,
avec nos actes,
notre langue,
elle,
finira toujours
par trahir
l'état réel
de notre cœur.
car c'est de l'abondance
du cœur
que la bouche parle.
Et le meilleur
triste exemple
que nous ayons
d'une telle hypocrisie
religieuse
dans la parole,
c'est l'exemple
des pharisiens
auxquels Jésus,
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
reprocha si souvent
d'être des sépulcres
blanchis,
propres à l'extérieur,
mais putrides
à l'intérieur.
Et c'est aussi
pour cela
qu'il était important
de rappeler l'arrière-plan
juif
des auditeurs de Jacques,
car il est fort probable
qu'avant leur conversion,
ils aient été infectés
eux aussi par ce venin,
ce levain des pharisiens
comme l'appelait Jésus-Christ,
qui peut-être
commençait à se diffuser
à nouveau
dans leur cœur
dans ces temps
très difficiles
qu'ils traversaient,
en les tentant
au compromis spirituel.
Il est donc pertinent
pour nous aussi
de nous rappeler
les reproches
que Jésus-Christ
adressait aux pharisiens,
car nous sommes tous,
reconnaissons-le,
frères et sœurs,
de potentiels pharisiens.
Nous pouvons tous
être tentés
de considérer
comme suffisants
de professer la foi
de notre bouche,
d'obéir
ou de faire semblant
d'obéir extérieurement
au commandement de Dieu,
de participer
de manière assidue
aux réunions d'Église
sans que notre cœur
ne soit réellement
et progressivement
davantage consacré
à Dieu,
attaché à Christ
et serviable
envers notre prochain.
Les pharisiens,
vous le savez,
formaient un groupe
religieux influent
parmi les Juifs
au temps de Jésus.
Ils étaient connus
principalement
pour leur stricte
observance
de la loi mosaïque,
en tout cas,
en théorie.
car cette observation
de la loi
dont ils se vantaient
si souvent
et à laquelle
ils n'avaient de cesse
de pousser durement
les autres
était en réalité,
nous le savons
car Jésus-Christ
nous l'a dit,
totalement hypocrite.
Et cela
pour trois raisons principales.
Non seulement
ils ne mettaient
tout simplement pas
en pratique
cette loi
eux-mêmes,
mais même
lorsque ça leur arrivait
de mettre en pratique
la loi,
c'était avec un cœur méchant,
un cœur rempli
d'orgueil,
d'un faux zèle
intéressé
pour leur propre gloire
et un cœur rempli
de mépris
envers Dieu
en réalité
et envers leurs prochains.
Et de plus,
troisième point,
la loi
qu'ils suivaient
était une tradition
humaine
qui bien souvent
contredisait
même les principes
de la loi morale
de Dieu
pour conforter
leur chair.
Et afin que nous saisissions
mieux
toutes les tendues
que cette hypocrisie religieuse
peut malheureusement avoir
dans la vie
d'un membre d'Église.
Voici donc
quelques reproches
que Jésus
adressa aux pharisiens.
Déjà,
comme je disais,
les pharisiens,
premier point,
ne mettaient tout simplement
pas en pratique
ce qu'ils enseignaient.
Et tous les textes
que je vais citer
sont des reproches
que Jésus
leur adresse directement.
Jésus dit
« Faites donc
et observez
tout ce qu'ils vous disent,
mais n'agissez pas
selon leurs œuvres,
car ils disent
et ne font pas.
Ils lient
des fardeaux pesants
en les mettant
sur les épaules
des hommes,
mais ils ne veulent pas
les remuer
du doigt. »
Ensuite,
le zèle
légaliste
des pharisiens
n'était en réalité
qu'un moyen
pour eux
de nourrir
l'orgueil
de leur chair.
Jésus dit
« Ils font
toutes leurs actions
pour être
vus des hommes.
Ainsi,
ils portent
de l'archiville
à terre,
ils ont
de longues franges
à leurs vêtements,
ils aiment
la première place
dans les festins
et les premiers sièges
dans la synagogue.
Ils aiment
être salués
dans les places publiques
et être appelés
par les hommes
« Rabbi, Rabbi ».
Et pour finir,
deux accusations
qui sont
plus proches
de ce que Jacques
exprime au verset 26.
sur les ailes extérieures
des pharisiens
qui étaient
déconnectés
de l'implication
et de la transformation
intérieure
de leur cœur.
Malheur à vous,
scribes et pharisiens
hypocrites,
parce que vous nettoyez
le dehors
de la coupe
et du plat,
tandis qu'au-dedans
ils sont pleins
de rapines
et d'intempérance.
Pharisien aveugle
nettoie premièrement
l'intérieur
de la coupe
et du plat
afin que l'extérieur
aussi
devienne nette.
Et ailleurs,
malheur à vous,
scribes et pharisiens
hypocrites,
parce que vous ressemblez
à des sépulcres blanchis
qui paraissent
beaux au-dehors
et qui au-dedans
sont pleins
d'ossements
de mort
et de toute espèce
d'impureté.
Vous de même,
au-dehors,
vous paraissez
juste aux hommes,
mais au-dedans,
vous êtes pleins
d'hypocrisie
et d'iniquité.
Voici donc
des hommes
qui sont
un condensé,
malheureusement,
de ce que Jacques
condamne
des versets 22
à 27.
Soit ils écoutent
et enseignent même
en ce qui les concerne
la parole de Dieu
sans la mettre
en pratique,
comme le cas
du verset 22,
soit,
comme au verset 26,
ils mettent en pratique
la loi,
mais avec un cœur
tellement rempli
de péchés
et de méchanceté
et d'orgueil
que leur langue
ne peut s'empêcher
de trahir
ainsi que l'affirme
Jésus-Christ
dans un autre passage.
Races de vipères.
Comment pourriez-vous
dire de bonnes choses ?
Méchants comme vous l'êtes,
car c'est de l'abondance
du cœur
que la bouche parle.
L'homme bon
tire de bonnes choses
du bon trésor
de son cœur
et le méchant
tire de mauvaises choses
de son mauvais trésor.
Et c'est précisément
pour cela que Jacques
a choisi la langue
pour mettre en évidence
la foi vaine
au verset 26.
Car notre langue
a cette capacité
de transpercer
le vernis religieux
dont nous pouvons
nous recouvrir
et de dévoiler
au grand jour
la réalité
de notre cœur
tel qu'il est.
Et il est très courant
d'observer
chez ces personnes
très assurées,
très fières
de leur pratique religieuse,
de leur légalisme,
qu'ils ne vont pas
appeler comme ça bien sûr,
une capacité
à médire
et à critiquer
les autres
qui ne sont pas
à la hauteur,
à leur hauteur
selon leurs critères,
qui sont des critères
charnels.
N'est-ce pas
ce que faisaient constamment
les pharisiens
envers Jésus
et envers ses disciples ?
Tellement sûrs
de leur justice propre,
tellement enflés
d'orgueil,
aveuglés
par leur orgueil.
Ils étaient
cependant incapables
de tenir en bride
leur langue
qui trahissait
sans arrêt
l'état spirituel
de leur cœur
qui était mauvais.
Au verset 26,
nous sommes face
à une personne
qui,
à l'image
de ces pharisiens,
est extérieurement
religieuse,
mais dont la langue
révèle un cœur impie
rempli d'hypocrisie
et d'iniquité.
Et Jacques affirme
que la religion
de cette personne
est inutile,
est futile.
Si notre langue
n'est pas domptée,
traduisant que notre cœur
n'a pas été transformé
et n'est pas progressivement
sanctifié par l'Évangile,
peu importe le nombre
de prières,
de connaissances,
d'activités
et de services religieux
que nous accomplirons,
cela ne servira à rien.
Tout cela sera futile,
vain et inutile.
Nous nous croirons
religieux peut-être,
mais notre religion
ne sera qu'un mirage
trompeur,
une vanité
qui mènera
notre âme
tout droit
en enfer.
Prenons garde
à ne pas devenir
nous aussi
des sépulcres blanchis,
paraissant beaux
à l'extérieur,
mais en réalité
remplis d'impuretés
à l'intérieur.
Mais l'hypocrisie
des pharisiens
allait encore plus loin
que juste faire semblant
d'obéir à la loi
de Dieu extérieurement.
Car c'est souvent à cela
qu'on s'arrête.
Mais parmi tous les passages
où Jésus les reprend,
il y en a un
qui nous montre bien
jusqu'où notre cœur mauvais
est capable d'aller
pour nous convaincre
nous-mêmes
et les autres
que nous sommes saints,
tout en conservant
et en préservant
les convoitises
de notre cœur
que notre cher corrompu
affectionne tant.
Et donc,
je vais lire ce passage
en Matthieu 15,
verset 1, 9.
Si vous voulez,
vous pouvez ouvrir
pour le lire avec moi.
Matthieu 15,
verset 1, 9.
Alors,
des pharisiens
et des scribes
vinrent de Jérusalem
auprès de Jésus
et dirent,
« Pourquoi tes disciples
transgressent-ils
la tradition des anciens ?
Car ils ne se lavent pas
les mains
quand ils prennent
leur repas. »
Il leur répondit,
« Et vous,
pourquoi transgressez-vous
le commandement de Dieu
au profit
de votre tradition ? »
Car Dieu a dit,
« Honore ton père
et ta mère. »
Et celui qui maudira
son père ou sa mère
sera puni de mort.
Mais vous,
vous dites,
celui qui dira
à son père
ou sa mère,
« Ce dont j'aurais pu
t'assister
est une offrande à Dieu
n'est pas tenu
d'honorer son père
ou sa mère. »
Vous annulez ainsi
la parole de Dieu
au profit
de votre tradition.
Hypocrite,
Esaïe a bien prophétisé
sur vous
quand il a dit,
« Ce peuple
m'honore des lèvres,
mais son cœur
est éloigné de moi. »
C'est en vain
qu'il m'honore
en enseignant des préceptes
qui sont des commandements
d'hommes.
Dans ce passage,
les pharisiens
reprochent
aux disciples de Jésus
de ne pas respecter
une tradition
orale humaine
qu'ils considéraient
aussi importante
que la loi de Dieu.
Donc,
premier point,
ils critiquent
un non-respect
extérieur
à un précepte
humain
extrait
d'une tradition
orale
et non
de la loi de Dieu.
Et ce qui se passe
ensuite est très intéressant.
Jésus leur rétorque
que leur obéissance
à leur tradition
humaine
est en réalité
une transgression
de la loi de Dieu.
Il va même
plus loin
en les accusant
d'utiliser
volontairement
cette tradition humaine
pour ne pas avoir
à obéir
à la loi de Dieu.
Le problème
des pharisiens,
ce n'était même pas
qu'ils obéissaient
seulement de manière extérieure
ou hypocrite
à la loi de Dieu.
Le problème,
c'est qu'ils avaient
bâti tout un édifice
de vains raisonnements
et de traditions humaines
contraires
à la loi de Dieu
afin d'agir
selon les convoitises
de leur chair
tout en se vantant
devant les hommes
d'être les plus
saints des saints
devant Dieu
car eux,
prétendaient-ils,
respectaient
la loi de Dieu
à la lettre.
Voyez jusqu'où peut
aller l'hypocrisie
religieuse d'un cœur
qui n'a pas été
transformé par l'Évangile
et qui se rend bien compte
que la loi de Dieu
est dure,
même impossible
à suivre
lorsqu'on comprend
ce qu'elle exige
vraiment de nous.
Il ne reste alors
qu'une possibilité
pour conserver
cette illusion
que nous pouvons être
juste devant Dieu
par notre obéissance
de la loi.
Il faut modifier
cette loi
pour en simplifier
les exigences,
aller même
jusqu'à établir
de nouveaux préceptes
qui contredisent
les principes bibliques
si cela nous permet
de paraître sains
devant les hommes
tout en gardant
notre même cœur pécheur
rempli des mêmes
convoitises charnelles.
Frères et sœurs,
malheureusement,
l'hypocrisie religieuse
des pharisiens
n'était pas nouvelle
car ces mots
que Jésus-Christ
leur adresse
à la fin du passage
que nous venons de lire
sont ceux que l'Éternel
prononça face
à la même hypocrisie
de son peuple
des siècles auparavant
par la bouche
du prophète Esaïe.
Le Seigneur dit
« Quand ce peuple
s'approche de moi,
il m'honore
de la bouche
et des lèvres
mais son cœur
est éloigné de moi
et la crainte
qu'il a de moi
n'est qu'un précepte
de tradition humaine. »
Malheureusement,
cette hypocrisie religieuse
existera toujours
tant que notre Seigneur
Jésus-Christ
ne sera pas revenu
pour y mettre fin.
Est-ce notre cas,
frères et sœurs ?
Avec quel cœur
sommes-nous venus
adorer Dieu ce matin ?
Quelle religion
pratiquons-nous
au quotidien ?
Quelle est la foi
qui nous anime ?
Est-ce qu'avec le temps,
nous sommes tombés
dans ce piège
de nous contenter
de notre mise
en pratique
des instructions bibliques,
de notre fidélité
à notre tradition
ecclésiastique
sans nous assurer
régulièrement
face au miroir
de la parole de Dieu,
que notre cœur
est toujours
véritablement consacré
et attaché
à Dieu ?
Et maintenant
que nous avons bien défini
en quoi consiste
cette religion hypocrite
et vaine
du verset 26,
j'aimerais vous montrer
que la religion authentique
dont parle Jacques
au verset 27,
celle qui est pure
et sans tâche
comme il le dit,
n'est pas non plus
une nouveauté
de la Nouvelle Alliance,
mais qu'elle a toujours
était la seule
et unique religion
que Dieu a voulu
pour son peuple
et qu'il a accepté
de recevoir
de sa part.
La foi des pharisiens
et de ceux
qui leur ressemblent
encore aujourd'hui
n'est qu'une vanité
parce qu'ils ont
complètement exclu
l'implication
et la transformation
de leur cœur
par le Saint-Esprit
de l'exercice
de leur foi,
de la mise en pratique
de leur foi.
Ils ont
une apparence
de piété,
mais ils renient
ce qui en fait
la force,
comme Paul l'écrit
à Timothée
au sujet d'enseignants
qui avaient le même
problème que les pharisiens.
Ceux qui pratiquent
cette vaine religion
finissent par se convaincre
eux-mêmes
par leur faux raisonnement
et en trompant leur cœur
par leur faux aile légaliste
qu'ils possèdent
et défendent
la vraie foi,
qu'ils incarnent
et pratiquent
la religion pure
et sans tâche
du Dieu d'Abraham,
d'Isaac
et de Jacob,
mais ces hommes
se bercent d'illusions.
Ils sont en réalité
des fils de perdition,
des fils de la géhenne,
car leur chair
est peut-être circoncise,
que ce soit physiquement
pour les Juifs
ou métaphoriquement
par l'obéissance
à la loi,
mais leur cœur,
lui,
n'est pas circoncis.
est la seule vraie foi
qui sauve,
la seule vraie religion
pure et sans tâche
que Dieu agrée
est celle
qui circoncise le cœur
et le transforme
en une source
dont jaillissent
un flot
de nouvelles bonnes pensées,
de bonnes affections
et de bonnes œuvres.
Le cœur,
tel que la Bible
présente symboliquement,
est la source
de notre être.
C'est lui
qui nous anime
dans tout ce que nous pensons,
désirons,
aimons
et faisons.
C'est notre moteur,
c'est aussi
notre gouvernail intérieur
qui nous fait avancer
dans une direction précise.
Aucune créature de Dieu
n'agit contrairement
à sa nature.
Et si la nature
de notre cœur mauvais
ne change pas,
alors nous resterons
des femmes
et des hommes mauvais.
peu importe
le type de religion
que nous pratiquerons
et le zèle
que nous y mettons,
cela n'y changera rien.
La circoncision du cœur
s'opère en nous
lorsque le Saint-Esprit
parle à la parole de Dieu,
nous l'avons dit,
nous régénère
et nous sanctifie
progressivement
en créant en nous
un cœur nouveau
avec de nouveaux désirs,
de nouvelles affections
qui sont opposées
à notre chair,
opposées à l'esprit du monde
et en rétablissant
une relation intérieure
authentique avec Dieu,
marquée par l'obéissance,
l'amour
et la repentance.
Cette consécration
et dévotion
de notre cœur
à Dieu
a toujours été
l'objectif
de la religion pure
et sans tâche
dont parle Jacques
au verset 27
et qu'il décrit
au même verset
comme étant
la préservation
des souillures
du monde.
La circoncision du cœur,
la sanctification
et la préservation
des souillures du monde,
tout cela désigne
la même chose,
la même réalité
dans notre vie chrétienne.
Et frères et sœurs,
il est absolument crucial
pour nous tous
de nous rappeler
que la seule religion
que Dieu a toujours
voulu pour son peuple
et qu'il a toujours
accepté de recevoir
de lui
de tout temps
est celle
qui engage
notre être
tout entier
comme nous l'avons chanté
ce matin,
notre cœur,
notre esprit
et notre corps.
Tu aimeras
le Seigneur ton Dieu
de tout ton cœur,
de toute ton âme,
de toute ta force
et de toute ta pensée
et ton prochain
comme toi-même.
Voici la synthèse
de toute la loi.
Voici la définition
de l'essence même
de notre humanité.
Voici ce que nous serions
si notre chair
n'était pas corrompue
par le péché.
Et voici ce vers quoi
nous devons donc progresser
en nous appuyant
sur le Saint-Esprit
qui nous transforme
de gloire en gloire
à l'image
de notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Et ce serait
une grave erreur
de penser
qu'un temps
Dieu se contentait
de la circoncision
de la chair
dans l'Ancien Testament.
Il serait faux
de croire
qu'il suffisait
d'être circoncis
dans la chair
et d'obéir extérieurement
à la loi de Moïse
même scrupuleusement
pour être agréable
à Dieu
et pour pratiquer
la vraie religion.
La vraie religion,
celle qui est pure
et sans tâche,
a toujours été celle
dont les œuvres
jaillissent d'un cœur
nouveau transformé
par la parole de Dieu,
véritablement consacré
et attaché
à Dieu.
Comme en témoignent
les versets suivants.
De Théronome 10,
verset 16.
Vous circoncierez donc
votre cœur
et vous ne rédirez
plus votre coup.
Jérémie 4,
verset 4.
Circoncisez-vous
pour l'éternel.
Circoncisez vos cœurs,
hommes de Juda
et habitants
de Jérusalem,
de peur que ma fureur
n'éclate comme un feu
et ne s'enflamme
sans qu'il n'y ait
personne pour l'éteindre
à cause de la méchanceté
de vos actions.
Et Jérémie 9,
verset 25.
Voici les jours
viennent,
dit l'Éternel,
où je châtirai
tous les circoncis
qui ne le sont pas
de cœur.
L'Égypte,
Juda et Dom,
les enfants d'Amon,
Moab et tous ceux
qui se rasent
les coins de la barbe
qui habitent dans le désert,
car toutes les nations
sont incirconcises
et toute la maison
d'Israël
a le cœur
incirconcis.
Ces versets
nous montrent bien
que ce que Dieu
a toujours désiré
et exigé
de son peuple,
c'est que son cœur
soit circoncis.
Lorsque,
comme le disait Esaïe,
son peuple
l'honorait de la bouche
en gardant un cœur
incirconcis,
la fureur de l'Éternel
les menaçait
d'extinction.
La circoncision du cœur
a donc toujours été
la source
et la finalité
de la vraie religion,
mais aussi
le problème fondamental
de l'être humain
qui,
depuis la chute,
est absolument incapable
de circoncire son cœur
par ses propres forces
en obéissant
à la loi de Dieu.
Et c'est pour cette raison
que Dieu a promis
de régler ce problème
en faisant cette promesse
à son peuple.
De Théronome 30,
verset 6,
l'Éternel,
ton Dieu,
circonciera ton cœur
et le cœur
de ta postérité
et tu aimeras
l'Éternel,
ton Dieu,
de tout ton cœur,
de toute ton âme,
afin que tu vives.
Ézéchiel 36,
verset 26,
c'est l'Éternel
qui parle,
« Je vous donnerai
un cœur nouveau
et je mettrai en vous
un esprit nouveau.
J'ôterai de votre corps
le cœur de pierre
et je vous donnerai
un cœur de chair.
Je mettrai mon esprit
en vous
et je ferai en sorte
que vous suiviez
mes ordonnances
et que vous observiez
et pratiquiez
mes lois. »
Et un dernier passage
qui nous montre
que Dieu accomplira
cette promesse
de changer le cœur
de son peuple
dans la Nouvelle Alliance
en Jésus-Christ.
« Mais voici l'alliance
que je ferai
avec la maison d'Israël
après ces jours-là,
dit l'Éternel.
Je mettrai ma loi
au-dedans d'eux.
Je l'écrirai
dans leur cœur
et je serai leur Dieu
et ils seront mon peuple. »
Et afin que la boucle
soit bouclée,
voici comment l'apôtre Paul
synthétise,
comme bien souvent,
à la perfection
tout ce que nous venons
de dire jusqu'à présent
dans cette prédication.
Je vais lire lentement
Romains 2,
versets 28 à 29.
« Le juif,
ce n'est pas celui
qui en a les apparences.
Et la circoncision,
ce n'est pas celle
qui est visible
dans la chair.
Mais le juif,
c'est celui
qui l'est intérieurement.
Et la circoncision,
c'est celle du cœur,
selon l'esprit
et non selon la lettre.
La louange de ce juif
ne vient pas des hommes,
mais de Dieu.
Amen.
Frères et sœurs,
le vrai croyant,
l'enfant de Dieu,
c'est celui
qui l'est d'abord
intérieurement
par la circoncision
de son cœur
opéré par Dieu.
Voici le dernier maillon
qui clôt l'œuvre
de cette chaîne
de la parole
de notre vie chrétienne.
Mais alors,
pourquoi Jacques,
après avoir mis
cette emphase
sur la transformation
nécessaire de notre cœur,
revient-il au verset 27
sur le sujet des œuvres
en nous encourageant
à visiter les orphelins
et les veuves
dans leurs afflictions ?
Ne nous a-t-il pas
déjà exhortés
à mettre en pratique
la parole
au verset 22 ?
Si Jacques termine
cette chaîne de la parole
par une dernière
exhortation pratique
au verset 27,
c'est parce que
nous devons comprendre
quelque chose
de tout à fait important
si nous voulons mener
une vie chrétienne
équilibrée
dans laquelle
les bonnes œuvres
trouvent leur juste place.
Sachant que j'entends
par bonnes œuvres
toute obéissance
au commandement
de Dieu
et toute conformité
de notre manière
de vivre
aux principes
que Dieu nous donne
dans sa parole.
Nous avons donc dit
qu'un cœur circoncis
ou régénéré,
sanctifié
par le Saint-Esprit
était la source
de la vraie religion.
Mais voici
ce qu'il est vraiment
essentiel de retenir
ce matin,
frères et sœurs.
Ce cœur nouveau
que nous recevons
de Dieu,
ce n'est pas seulement
la source
qui produit
nos bonnes œuvres,
c'est aussi
le destinataire
de ces bonnes œuvres
qui,
à leur tour,
continuent
de parfaire
sa sanctification.
Lorsque Jésus-Christ,
par l'Esprit Saint,
œuvre en nous
de cette manière,
il met en place
dans notre vie
un cercle vertueux
qui unit notre cœur
et nos bonnes œuvres.
Notre cœur,
régénéré par Dieu
et abreuvé par Christ,
produit de bonnes œuvres.
Dieu utilise
ces bonnes œuvres
que nous pratiquons
avec persévérance
pour sanctifier
notre cœur
qui est ainsi
toujours plus disposé
et capable
de produire
ces bonnes œuvres
et ainsi de suite.
Notre obéissance
à la loi de Dieu
est à la fois
le fruit
de notre cœur
régénéré,
mais aussi
l'outil
que Dieu utilise
pour continuer
son œuvre
de régénération,
de sanctification
en nous.
Il est vraiment important,
je pense,
de bien comprendre
ce point,
car non seulement
nous pourrons mieux
apprécier l'importance
et l'utilité
des bonnes œuvres
pour notre foi,
mais nous comprendrons
aussi mieux
pourquoi Dieu nous demande
de faire certaines choses
en particulier.
Car si nous considérons
notre obéissance
à la loi de Dieu
uniquement comme
un fruit
attendu et logique
d'un cœur nouveau,
comme une fin en soi,
qui ne revient pas
vers nous
pour produire
quelque chose
en nous,
en retour,
alors nous aurons
du mal à saisir
toute la pertinence
de certaines ordonnances
de Dieu.
Prenons par exemple
cette exhortation
de Jacques au verset 27.
La religion pure
et sans tâche
devant Dieu notre Père
consiste à visiter
les orphelins
et les veuves
dans leurs afflictions.
Alors d'un premier abord,
nous pourrions nous dire,
et nous aurons raison
de dire cela,
qu'il est normal
pour un chrétien
de prendre soin
des plus démunis.
C'est notre appel
à nous qui avons tant
reçu de la part de Dieu.
C'est notre appel
de servir
et de bénir
notre prochain
en retour.
Et c'est vrai.
Et il y aurait
énormément de choses
à dire rien qu'à ce sujet.
Mais j'aimerais
vous montrer ici
plus spécifiquement
cette manière,
et la liste
n'est pas exhaustive,
cette manière
dont ces bonnes œuvres
reviennent vers notre cœur
par lequel elles sont produites
pour le sanctifier.
Et donc,
entretiennent concrètement
notre expérience intérieure
de la vraie religion
telle que nous l'avons définie
plus tôt,
celle qui circoncie le cœur.
Premièrement,
les bonnes œuvres
renforcent notre amour
pour Dieu
et pour les autres.
Lorsque nous pratiquons
ces bonnes œuvres,
surtout celles,
comme au verset 27,
qui consistent à aimer
et servir les autres
et les plus démunis,
notre amour pour Dieu
et pour les autres
s'approfondit.
Et donc,
cette pratique
de la charité
nous transforme
et purifie notre cœur,
le rendant plus conforme
à la volonté de Dieu.
1 Jean 3, verset 18,
N'aimons pas en parole
et avec la langue,
mais en action
et avec vérité.
Par là,
nous connaîtrons
que nous sommes de la vérité
et nous rassurerons
nos cœurs devant lui,
c'est-à-dire devant Dieu.
Les bonnes œuvres
témoignent
de l'authenticité
de notre foi,
certes,
mais elles fortifient
aussi notre cœur
dans l'amour
et dans la charité.
Deuxièmement,
les bonnes œuvres
cultivent l'humilité
et la dépendance
envers Dieu.
Philippiens 2, verset 3,
Ne faites rien
par esprit de partie
ou par vaigne gloire,
mais que l'humilité
vous fasse regarder
les autres
comme étant au-dessus
de vous-même,
que chacun de vous,
au lieu de considérer
ses propres intérêts,
considère aussi
ceux des autres.
Donc,
en servant les autres,
en mettant en pratique
ces œuvres de charité,
nous apprenons
concrètement
l'humilité.
L'humilité
qui est essentielle
à la sanctification
et en nous détachant
ainsi de nous-mêmes,
de notre égoïsme,
nous nous rapprochons
davantage de Dieu.
Nous sommes davantage
en communion avec Dieu
et nous devenons
plus sensibles
à sa volonté.
Jacques,
plus loin dans sa lettre,
dit
Dieu résiste aux orgueilleux,
mais il fait grâce
aux humbles.
Donc,
ces œuvres de service,
de sacrifice personnel,
nous humilient
et nous préparent
à recevoir
la grâce de Dieu
qui est essentielle
à notre sanctification.
Troisièmement,
les bonnes œuvres
nous disciplinent
et nous affermissent
dans la foi.
Paul dit,
un Corinthien,
« Mais je traite durement
mon corps
et je le tiens assujetti
de peur d'être moi-même
disqualifié
après avoir prêché
aux autres. »
La pratique
des bonnes œuvres,
particulièrement
lorsque ça demande
sacrifice de nous-mêmes
et persévérance
dans l'épreuve,
nous discipline
spirituellement.
et cette discipline
fortifie à son tour
notre foi
et nous aide
à vivre de manière
plus cohérente
avec les enseignements
de Christ.
Hébreux 12,
verset 11,
« Il est vrai
que tout châtiment
semble d'abord
un sujet de tristesse
et non de joie,
mais il produit
plus tard
pour ceux
qui ont été
ainsi exercés
un fruit paisible
de justice. »
Les bonnes œuvres,
bien qu'elles soient
souvent difficiles
pour notre chair,
produisent
un fruit de justice
et contribuent
à la purification
et à la sanctification
de notre cœur.
Quatrièmement,
les bonnes œuvres
témoignent
de notre foi
et nous affirmissent
dans notre identité
en Christ.
Il en est ainsi
de la foi
si elle n'a pas
les œuvres,
elle est morte
en elle-même.
Donc ne vous inquiétez pas,
j'ai prévu
de prêcher
une dizaine
de sermons
rien que sur ce verset
de Jacques
plus loin dans sa lettre.
Mais pour le moment,
notez simplement
que les bonnes œuvres
sont le fruit
d'une foi vivante.
Elles témoignent
non seulement
aux autres
que nous avons
la foi salvatrice
en Christ,
mais aussi
à nous-mêmes,
renforçant
l'assurance
que nous avons
de posséder
cette foi.
Éphésiens 2,
verset 10,
« Car nous sommes
son ouvrage
ayant été créés
en Jésus-Christ
pour de bonnes œuvres
que Dieu a préparées
d'avance
afin que nous
les pratiquions. »
En pratiquant
les bonnes œuvres,
encore une fois,
pour lesquelles
Dieu nous a créés
et régénérés,
nous vivons pleinement
notre identité
en Christ
et nous grandissons
en sainteté.
Cinquièmement,
les bonnes œuvres
augmentent
et approfondissent
notre communion
avec Dieu.
Jean 4,
verset 21,
« Celui qui a mes commandements
et qui les garde,
c'est celui qui m'aime.
Et celui qui m'aime
sera aimé de mon Père.
Je l'aimerai
et je me manifesterai
à lui. »
Donc,
en pratiquant
les bonnes œuvres,
nous vivons
dans l'obéissance
au commandement de Dieu,
ce qui renforce
notre relation intime
avec lui.
Cette communion
accrue
avec Dieu
nous rapproche
de la source
de toute sainteté
qui est Christ
et nous transforme
à son image.
Sixièmement,
les bonnes œuvres
nous aident
à surmonter
les tentations.
Romains 13,
verset 14,
« Mais revêtez-vous
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ
et ne vous laissez pas
aller au désir
de la chair. »
En nous engageant
activement
dans les bonnes œuvres,
nous concentrons
nos pensées,
toute notre énergie
sur ce qui est
saint et pur
et cela diminue
la place
pour les tentations
et les désirs
charnels
dans nos pensées,
dans ce que nous faisons
dans notre vie.
Et dernier point,
les bonnes œuvres
apportent
la joie spirituelle.
Jean 15,
verset 10,
« Si vous gardez
mes commandements,
vous demeurez
dans mon amour,
de même que j'ai gardé
les commandements
de mon Père
et que je demeure
dans son amour.
Je vous dis cela
afin que ma joie
soit en vous
et que votre joie
soit parfaite. »
Donc, en accomplissant
les bonnes œuvres,
nous expérimentons
la joie de marcher
dans l'obéissance
à Dieu,
une joie qui découle
de notre union
avec Christ
et qui complète
notre sanctification.
Comme je le disais,
cette liste n'est pas exhaustive
et le temps nous manque
pour la développer davantage,
mais voici,
simplement en les citant,
d'autres bienfaits spirituels
que notre pratique
de bonnes œuvres
nous apporte.
Elles nous permettent
de demeurer
dans la lumière de Dieu,
elles purifient
notre conscience
et elles nous préparent
pour les récompenses célestes.
Les bonnes œuvres
que nous pratiquons
ne sont donc pas seulement,
frères et sœurs,
des expressions
de notre foi,
mais elles sont aussi,
elles ont aussi
un effet transformateur
sur notre cœur
dont elles sont le fruit.
Elles nous rapprochent
de Dieu,
elles cultivent
dans notre cœur
des vertus essentielles
à notre maturité spirituelle
comme l'humilité
et l'amour.
Elles nous disciplinent
spirituellement,
elles affirmissent
notre identité en Christ,
elles jouent donc
un rôle crucial
dans notre processus
de sanctification
et nous devrions
les chérir pour cela
et les rechercher
et les pratiquer
pour cela.
Et parmi toutes
les bonnes œuvres
que nous pouvons accomplir,
il y en a peu
qui ont autant
cette capacité
de nous sanctifier
que de nous mettre,
que de mettre
ce que nous possédons
au service
de notre prochain
et en particulier
de ceux
qui ont le moins
comme Jacques
nous y encourage
au verset 27.
Et Jacques ne fait
ici que nous rappeler
un principe
qui encore une fois
n'est pas nouveau
puisque l'on retrouve
ce principe
à de nombreuses reprises
dans l'Ancien Testament
ainsi que dans
les enseignements
de Jésus-Christ
prouvant une nouvelle fois
que la substance
de la vraie religion
n'a jamais changé.
Ésaïe 58, verset 6
L'Éternel parle
Voici le jeûne
auquel je prends plaisir.
Détache les liens
de la méchanceté.
Dénoue les cordes
de la servitude.
Renvoie libre
les opprimés
et que l'on rompe
toute espèce de joug.
Partage ton pain
avec celui qui a faim
et fais entrer
dans ta maison
les malheureux
sans asile.
Si tu vois un homme nu,
couvre-le
et ne te détourne pas
de ton semblable.
Ce passage
des Ésaïes
met l'accent sur
l'importance pour nous
de pratiquer la justice
et la charité
montrant que
la vraie religion
le vrai culte
auquel Dieu
prend plaisir
comme il le dit
Voici le jeûne
auquel je prends plaisir
cette vraie religion
se manifeste
par des actes
de miséricorde
envers
ceux qui en ont besoin.
Proverbe 19, verset 17
Un verset intéressant
à ce sujet
Celui qui a pitié du pauvre
prête à l'éternel
qui lui rendra
selon son oeuvre.
Ce verset nous enseigne
que faire preuve
de générosité
envers les pauvres
ce n'est pas seulement
envers eux
que nous le faisons
mais c'est en quelque sorte
un acte
que l'on fait
directement envers Dieu
et que Dieu
récompensera
cette bonté.
Et c'est un principe
que Jésus reprend
lorsqu'il dit
dans une de ses paraboles
et le roi
leur répondra
je vous le dis
en vérité
toutes les fois
que vous avez fait cela
à l'un de ses plus petits
de mes frères
c'est à moi
que vous l'avez fait.
Et ailleurs
quiconque donnera
seulement un verre d'eau fraîche
à l'un de ses petits
parce qu'il est mon disciple
je vous le dis en vérité
il ne perdra point
sa récompense.
Jésus-Christ
a explicitement enseigné
que nous devions
inviter
ceux qui ne peuvent pas
nous rendre l'appareil.
Luc 14 verset 12
il dit aussi
à celui
qui l'avait invité
lorsque tu donnes
à dîner
ou à souper
n'invite pas tes amis
ni tes frères
ni tes parents
ni des voisins riches
de peur qu'ils ne t'invitent
à leur tour
et qu'on ne te rende l'appareil.
Mais lorsque tu donnes
un festin
invite des pauvres
des estropiés
des boiteux
et des aveugles
et tu seras heureux
de ce qu'ils ne peuvent
pas te rendre l'appareil.
Pourquoi ?
Car elle te sera rendue
à la résurrection
des justes.
Bien entendu
même cette recommandation
de Christ
peut être pratiquée
de manière légaliste
et superficielle
sans que le cœur
ne soit engagé.
Mais cette catégorie
de personnes
que Jacques
nous appelle
à servir
et à bénir
dans leurs afflictions
favorise
un vrai service
un don sacrificiel
de notre part
qui cultive
comme nous l'avons dit
en retour
la sanctification
de notre cœur
qui est le but
du salut
que Christ
accomplit pour nous.
Et c'est ainsi
que nous devrions voir
notre activité chrétienne
dont parle Jacques
au verset 25.
Nous devons être
intentionnels
frères et sœurs
en choisissant
de nous mettre
volontairement
dans des situations
qui nourrissent
et font croître
la religion
pure et sans tâche
dans notre cœur.
Et en faisant cela
nous serons
non seulement
heureux
dans notre activité
sur terre
mais jusque
dans l'éternité.
Ainsi que l'affirme
le Christ
tu seras heureux
de ce qu'ils ne peuvent
pas te rendre
la pareille
car elle te sera rendue
à la résurrection
des justes.
Et donc
servir ainsi
notre prochain
avec une générosité
désintéressée
nous aide
à garder les yeux
fixés
sur la vie éternelle
sur les récompenses
célestes
ce qui a évidemment
un impact positif
considérable
sur l'état spirituel
de notre cœur
et entretient
ce cercle vertueux
en favorisant
notre pratique
des bonnes œuvres
que notre Père Céleste
a préparé d'avance
pour nous.
Voici donc
ce à quoi Jacques
nous encourage
dans ce verset 27
à entrer
dans ce cercle vertueux
dans lequel
notre cœur
est généré
produit de bonnes œuvres
qui le sanctifie
en retour.
Pour conclure
frères et sœurs
prenons garde
à ne pas
séparer
notre cœur
de nos œuvres
et nos œuvres
de notre cœur.
Gardons-nous
de l'hypocrisie religieuse
examinons sincèrement
nos cœurs
afin de
nous assurer
que nous ne
nous trompons pas
nous-mêmes
quant à l'authenticité
de notre foi
avec un cœur
qui resterait
inchangé
au contact
de la parole
de Dieu
et de nos œuvres.
La parole
nous enseigne explicitement
que Dieu
nous a sauvés
pour que nous soyons saints,
pour que nous pratiquions
de bonnes œuvres
et nous ne pouvons pas
pratiquer ces bonnes œuvres
sans que notre cœur
nous soit
continuellement
sanctifié
par la parole de Dieu.
Ne méprisons pas
le sang
que Christ a versé
en nous privant
d'entrer
dans ce cercle vertueux
qui unit nos cœurs
à nos œuvres
et qui est destiné
à le glorifier,
à honorer
sa justice
et son sacrifice parfait.
N'oublions pas
que Jésus-Christ
est venu sur terre
accomplir tout ce qui était
nécessaire à notre salut
précisément
pour que nous soyons saints,
transformés
à son image
selon la volonté du Père
qui l'a envoyée.
Nous avons l'assurance
qu'il a parfaitement
accompli la loi
à notre place
en nous justifiant
devant Dieu,
en sécurisant
notre salut éternel.
Mais ce n'est pas
parce que Jésus-Christ
a parfaitement
accompli la loi
à notre place
que nous ne sommes pas appelés
à nous y conformer.
et à lui ressembler
de plus en plus
en travaillant
à notre sanctification.
Que Dieu notre Père
entende cette prière
et nous sanctifie
par son Saint-Esprit
à l'image de son Fils
pour le bien
de notre âme
et pour la gloire
de son Saint-Nom.